foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror now it's only a week until
Halloween and like many of you guys I
would assume I've actually been
preparing myself for the very best day
of the whole entire year by watching you
know creepy Autumn tinged movies and
reading creepy Autumn tinged books which
you know is really not that different to
what I'm doing the rest of the year uh
not gonna lie about that
so imagine my delight when I came across
this brand new Anthology this was just
published in September of 2022 and it's
called literally dead Tales of Halloween
hauntings by various authors and imagine
my even greater excitement when I saw
that I could read it for free on my good
old Kindle unlimited subscription which
has paid for itself many many times over
at this point so I think what drew me to
this book in particular I mean other
than it being Halloween themed and being
new and being free you know not gonna
lie uh was that amazing amazing cover
art which really really captured so much
of the magic of the Halloween holiday
for me so it was actually with I was
really interested to read the
introduction of the book which was
actually written by the cover artist uh
herself whose name is Lynn Hansen now it
turns out that she did this original
piece not as a book cover but she
actually did it um for like as a poster
for a Halloween charity event back in
2021 uh which was raising money for the
little victories animal rescue
hence why there's like a little dog and
a little Ghost Dog on it so when another
writer and an editor named Gabby Triana
saw that poster she liked it so much
that she decided to base an entire
horror Anthology around this particular
like somewhat nostalgic aesthetic that
it had and essentially you know I think
this was implied like using the art as a
brief like for the contributing authors
like what kind of vibe they were going
for and I have to say that most of the
authors in this collection like
absolutely came through Aces if you're
really looking for something that's
going to put you in that very wistful
like spellbinding Halloween mood that
you kind of remember from childhood most
of the stories here will absolutely do
the trick in that regard having said
that though there is a nice diversity of
themes and styles like among the 19
stories which are in here so there
really is something for pretty much
everybody I found all the stories
excellent and I enjoyed reading all of
them even though if you weren't suited
to my particular taste but that's going
to happen with any Anthology you know I
like certain things more than others and
you know and when I was reading like
some other reviews of it there aren't
that many because this is very very new
it just came out last month but you know
some of the stories that I was kind of
like oh you know it's not really my
thing but some you know other people
that was like their favorite story so
there's gonna be like something in here
for like I said pretty much everybody
most of the stories are pretty short and
sweet
um and they kind of run the gamut from
the more cheeky hilarious end to the
more pensive and Melancholy end uh
there's even like a good variety of
settings in here like you have some more
maybe like obvious or I don't want to
say cliched but it's more obvious
settings like you know Salem
Massachusetts and New Orleans and stuff
but there's also one that's set in Wales
there's one that's set in China that's
kind of like a Chinese folklore folk
tale uh that's one in Ukraine there's
kind of one in like Chicago hoods stuff
like that so there's kind of like a vast
array of different things going on I
especially liked in this book that most
of the stories were focused Less on Gore
there is some there is like a little bit
in some of the stories but this these
stories seemed more like focused a lot
on like atmosphere like it leaned really
hard into the whole like swirling Dead
Leaves and like Chilly Winds and like
darker nights as fall approaches and
stuff so this collection is like really
heavy on the spooky and relatively light
on the gruesome although there is some
gory stuff in here that's not like the
primary focus so the first story which
is called the Curiosity at the back of
the fridge by Catherine Cavendish is
like a really good fitting way to start
off the Anthology it's again quite short
um in it's kind of like a little more
folkloric like a fairy tale a little bit
about this kind of poverty-stricken
bullied little boy named Brian who ends
up befriending this kind of weird old
man named Bobby Clem who lives in this
ramshackle old house just outside his
Village People kind of whisper things
about Bobby Clem like he's a little bit
weird or he's like a recluse or
something like that but uh Brian
actually finds him very very nice very
kind very generous and particularly on
Halloween when he lays out a massive
Feast almost like Thanksgiving with like
a turkey and everything like that this
food being provided by a weird being
that he calls the Curiosity who lives in
his refrigerator so that's all I'm going
to say about that one so that story is
followed up by a story called a
bookstore made of skulls Salem
Massachusetts by Maureen Mancini and
Maturo and this is kind of like more I
guess more like a vignette than a story
really but it's very very atmospheric
and it's told in the first person like
about an unnamed narrator who kind of
like ducks into this weird bookstore
like she's been to Salem lots of times
but she's never seen this bookstore
before and it's really really cool
looking with all these like molded
skulls and stuff like on the outside so
it's just kind of like her weird
experiences like in This Book story you
know what I mean it's almost was kind of
like she goes into another dimension
like you know the clocks like there's
nobody in there and like all the books
look exactly the same and like all the
clocks like keep changing times and
stuff like that so I really really liked
it as somebody that you know personally
really really likes bookstores
um I kind of like vibed with this one a
lot too so the third story was called
postcards from Evelyn by Scott Cole and
this actually reminded me of one of my
own stories which is called uh neither
rain nor sleet which I think was in my
Associated villainy's uh collection uh
in this story there's a man named Andrew
and he starts getting these postcards
like through his mail slot from someone
named Evelyn inviting him to her
Halloween party and it's Halloween like
spelled with the apostrophe in the
middle like the old time anyway but all
the postcards um are postmarked in 1910
and they all look really old and the
sentiment on the cards like starts to
get more and more cranky like as
Halloween approaches and he doesn't
reply to them so that's all I'm gonna
say about that but this was a good one
too like I said very very Halloween very
like vintage Halloween because of you
could imagine the aesthetic of the
postcards and stuff so like I said the
whole book isn't like that but a lot of
the stories do kind of like lean into
that not necessarily vintage but that
kind of like old school like spooky like
chilly Halloween kind of vibe which I
really really dug so actually one of my
favorites in the Anthology was the
Crawlers in the corn by David's surface
and this is kind of like a spooky
monster story about two 14 year old boys
who've been best friends for a long time
uh one of them Danny is still all about
Halloween but the other one whose name
is Carl is kind of like pretending to be
too old for that [ __ ] like he's drinking
beer that he stole from his dad and like
listening to terrible Jazz like he's so
like wearing like a like a Hugh Hefner
robe like he's some kind of
sophisticated [ __ ] isn't like
that he's like oh we're too old for
Halloween that's kid stuff blah blah
blah uh but as The Story Goes On like it
comes to light that Carl is actually not
really so much over Halloween as he's
just like really really scared by these
creatures that are called the Crawlers
that they've called the Crawlers in the
corn which Danny apparently like
summoned with his imagination since the
two boys there's like a like a really
big like vast creepy cornfield like
right across the street from Carl's
house and they've been making up stories
about all this stuff that happened in
there like for a long time so this story
is almost kind of like the power of like
childhood imagination and the way that
children like really scary things like
particularly around this time of year so
I really really liked this one as well
so the next three stories like after
that tended more toward the sorrowful
end all of them examined grief in some
way uh there was when they fall by Steve
rasnick tem uh this is kind of like a
tragic story about a man named Ralph who
now lives alone in this creepy old house
that was once this big Showplace uh he
used to share it with his wife and two
children and it's implied that the place
is haunted and over the course of the
story you kind of discover what happened
to Ralph's family so this is just like a
really really creepy almost kind of like
a classic ghost story and it's very very
a very atmospheric piece just kind of
oozes these chili Autumn Vibes and
sadness and stuff like that so I really
like this one a lot as well then there
was always October by Jeremy mcgargey
I'm hoping I'm pronouncing that right
I'm if I'm not I apologize uh and by the
same token this is actually about a I
guess quote unquote Ghost Hunter who it
seems like is going around on Halloween
when the veil between the living and the
dead is the thinnest and it seems like
he's collecting ghosts and like ghosts
and like drawing them into himself
though the real story is a little bit
different than what that would imply and
then there's another story called how to
unmake a ghost by Sarah tantlinger and
this is another very heartbreaking story
written in the second person from the
point of view of a ghost who has been
summoned by her girlfriend and it's
essentially like a story of like a dead
woman begging the woman that she loves
to let her go and to like just go on and
live her life rather than wallowing in
grief so this was like a theme of
several stories in there which actually
I kind of liked but I'm just saying that
if you're not real into
they're not all the stories aren't sad
there's like a wide gamut but there are
like a lot of really sad stories where
like mournful wistful type of stories
which like I said really vibed with the
whole Halloween thing to me because
that's always what Halloween seemed like
but if you want something more like
monstery or gory or something like that
then you know then maybe this wouldn't
be for you but I don't know I I just
kind of liked the whole vibe of this one
so then we get into another one of my
favorite stories in this which was a
hilarious tale called a Halloween visit
by Dana hammer and this is about this
vain elderly woman named Gabriella and
she used to be like some kind of big
famous jazz singer back in the day but
like now she's in her 80s
um and she's kind of one of those old
ladies that still like walks around in
like Silk robes and like those those
like high-heeled slipper shoes that have
like the fuzz on the toes yeah she's
like has those uh so she on Halloween
night she gets like this very late
trick-or-treater who turns out to be
like an actual Grim Reaper who insists
on being called Emma so the dialogue
between like the old woman and the
reaper is just hysterical it was just
very very sparkling and fun this one was
just kind of like a good time all around
so there are like funny ones in here as
well there are like a couple of funny
ones and you know by all accounts like
all the funny ones like really do hit
they are very very funny and this one is
actually really hilarious then there is
bootsy's house by Dennis K Crosby and
this is about two guys in Chicago who go
into this notorious haunted house on
Halloween night to retrieve six hundred
thousand dollars from a previous type a
previous Heist like a guy like stole a
bunch of money and then hid out in this
house like with the loot but then like
the perp like came out the house and he
was like went crazy like presumably by
whatever he saw in there so I have to
say I really really love the imagery in
this one the way it was described it
reminded me slightly of The People Under
the Stairs but Supernatural it wasn't
like human monsters it was actual ghosts
so the next one is called Soul Cakes by
Catherine McCarthy and that one this one
is set in Wales and it's other another
kind of like mournful story I guess like
about grief and loss and stuff and most
of it is revolving around a woman named
bethan who is making Soul cakes with her
grandmother but we discover at the end
that things aren't exactly what they
seem so like I said a lot of these are
like kind of sad ghost stories but I was
into that but the next one was another
funny one uh and this one was also like
pretty disgusting but like in a comical
way uh it was called ghosts of candies
past by Jeff Strand and this had a great
great setup uh it's told from the point
of view of like a dad whose kids come
back from trick-or-treating but all the
candy they got is like old timey candy
like candy they don't they either don't
make any more or vintage versions of
candy that are still around like there's
Hershey bars in there but they have like
the old rappers on them from like 30 40
50 years ago I won't really spoil what
happens you won't be able to guess uh
but it's really fun and it's uh pretty
pretty gross so this is actually one of
the ones that if you're into like more
Gore Warrior disgusting type stuff then
this would probably be the one for you
and like I said it's pretty [ __ ]
funny also and then there's another kind
of uh more classic ghost story uh that
end told from the perspective of a ghost
named Katie and it's called Halloween at
The Babylon by Lisa Morton and it's
about a performer who died in an
accident like a century before and she's
haunted this theater The Babylon ever
since
um there's also another horrible
something uh that's haunting the place
and Katie is like attempting to
communicate with this group of Ghost
Hunters that come there on Halloween
like you know to help her out or like
try to get someone to talk to her and
try to figure out like what this other
something is that's haunting the place
and then the next story a lot more
topical take this was kind of like
um one that was a lot different than the
other stories it was kind of light on
the Halloween Vibes not gonna lie it was
mentioned that it was Halloween and
stuff but this one was called that I'm
sure I'm gonna pronounce this wrong but
it was called ghost of enter hodar and
her hodar by Henry Hertz or hers
uh it's set actually during the current
Uh Russian uh invasion of Ukraine and it
describes like a Russian attack that's
thwarted by some kind of folkloric
monsters like from Ukrainian folklore uh
this one I have to say wasn't really my
cup of tea uh being very heavy on the
descriptions of military hardware and
battle jargon and stuff like that so
it's more of like a dude's type of story
I guess but it was exceptionally well
written and researched and I really did
like the kind of well because I didn't
know and the guy says this in his author
notes I wasn't aware that they celebrate
Halloween in Ukraine but not like in
Russia you know what I mean so he kind
of used that a little bit like I said
not really my thing but I saw some
reviews that thought this was their
favorite story and it's definitely one
that is a lot different than the other
ones
um but like I said it's kind of light on
the Halloween Vibe so just know that
going in now the next story The Ghost
Lake mermaid uh by alethea kontis
alethia or Alafaya I'm sorry if I'm
pronouncing your name wrong uh was
another one of the best ones in the
collection in my opinion uh it's
actually about it's very very urban
legend which I really like that kind of
vibe too urban legend is very cool about
a Small Town Lake which Harbors at least
two ghosts and like I said there are a
bunch of urban legends about it
including one about a mermaid uh the
town is actually run by this shitty
family of bullies and criminals and
various miscreants uh who are called The
Buckle family and they've covered
covered up like a bunch of crimes and
like you know the the guys are like up
in the cops and [ __ ] like that so they
get away with a bunch of stuff but
inside the lake meanwhile uh the new
ghost of a murdered woman arrives and
attempts to get Justice for her own
death and also help the mermaid of the
legend uh so yeah this one was really
cool like the interaction between the
ghosts and like what they're trying to
do like how they can impact the living
and like get Justice for their own
deaths and stuff like that so the next
one was set in New Orleans and it was
called pink lace and death Gods by Eva
Roslyn this one came across as slightly
disjointed uh for me but a lot of people
I saw did really like this one I did
like this one overall it's about this
woman who buys this like fabulous dress
from a costume shop like it calls to her
and everything but then like later on
when she where will she when she tries
it on she's going to a hot to a
Halloween party but then at some point
she like switches bodies with this other
woman named Eloise and like Baron samity
is involved uh and stuff like that like
I said it seemed a little disjointed but
um you know it but it's a good story
overall and I did see that a lot of
people had picked it as their favorite
so another one that actually had pretty
much nothing to do with Halloween uh but
was pretty cool nonetheless was one
called the ghost Cricket by Lee Murray
it's basically a Chinese folk tale about
like a Dishonored Prince and his mother
who's a concubine and they're kind of
cast out of the palace and they are left
with nothing but you know the dead
Patriarchs Lucky Cricket like in the
little box
um and it keeps the prince awake all the
time with its constant screeching uh
until he takes some drastic measures
which uh don't end up going too well for
him so the next one no one sings In the
City of the Dead by Tim Wagoner like
some of the other ones in the in the
collection centered around grief and
kind of like the difficulty in letting
loved ones go and it's about this woman
whose husband dies of liver failure and
she ends up taking some very Extreme
Measures to like bring him back from the
dead uh and like I said now that I think
about it there were a lot of sad stories
in this Anthology but I really liked
that because I kind of found that more
in line with like the Halloween mood
like I said I'm more into like spooky
like ghost story like that kind of stuff
because it just gives me that wistful
you know approach of winter thinking
about death spooky ghost stories so I
really liked that Vibe so a lot of the
stories like that as I mentioned earlier
are like that in this Anthology but
that's why this one like really screamed
Halloween to me so the last two stories
in the collection were also pretty
somber and also among the best in the
book in my opinion uh a scavenger hunt
when the veil is thin by Gwendolyn
kissed or kissy not sure how you
pronounce what's that last name so I
apologize if it's wrong was about this
young woman who gets drawn back to this
small town which is kind of like a
closed-minded kind of town that she grew
up in and she's like since escaped it
but she gets drawn back there to
complete this traditional Halloween
scavenger hunt at the local haunted
house like everybody in town has to do
it or whatever but she discovers that
the reasons for the townspeople keeping
the tradition of the scavenger hunt
alive were not exactly what she thought
they were so this was actually like a
really good story as well and last but
certainly not least when you see
millions of the mouth was dead across
your dreams and pale battalions go by
Jonathan Mayberry I think this was
probably my favorite in the entire
Anthology if you held the gun in my head
and made me pick one uh it was also I
feel like it was the longest like the
mermaid Lake one was slightly long too
but I mean it's still pretty short but I
feel like this was the longest one it
gave me like a very Stephen King uh
nostalgic kind of vibe because because
it kind of explored the aftermath of the
Vietnam War like in particular the
Ripple effects that it had on people
when they came back home so it's about
this guy named Joey and he's reminiscing
about his older brother Alex who had
volunteered for the Air Force in 1965 uh
talking all of his friends into signing
up too because he thought he wouldn't
have to go to the front lines like he
would maybe just stay Stateside or
whatever but then like ending up pretty
much getting most of his friends killed
uh in Vietnam so most of the story is
actually set in the present day like
when Joey is an old man and his older
brother Alex shows up at his house in La
like out of the blue like asking for
forgiveness so this one is kind of like
a very heartbreaking like Bittersweet
story
um and also very affecting very
emotionally affecting uh and had like a
real gut punch of an ending even though
like you could kind of see it coming
like when she got to a certain point but
I think that just made it a lot more
poignant for me so yeah this one was
like a really really good story very
very like a lot of emotional depth to it
so yeah I mean if you're gearing up for
Halloween and want a book full of just
Eerie fall goodness to get you kind of
like in the proper headspace most of the
stories here will be you know very very
welcome additions to your Halloween
rotation uh some of the stories here are
more Halloween forward than others but
you know it's an anthology that's gonna
happen uh but like I said if your tastes
run more toward more spooky sorrowful
Ghostly and funny kind of end of the
Halloween Spectrum rather than maybe
like the Gory bloody slasher end or
Monster end uh then there's absolutely
gonna be something here that you know
that you'll really get into and you'll
really dig
um and like I said I think this is
definitely going to be a book that I'm
going to add into my yearly Halloween
rotation because I have like certain
movies that I'll watch every year
certain books that I like to read at
this time of year and I think this one's
definitely going in there because there
was enough stories in here that really
gave me that especially like in the
first half of the book I feel like the
first three or four or five stories were
like super super like how Halloween
forward and I was like and I was totally
there for it but yeah if you have Kettle
unlimited uh this is on there for free
it's very very new like I said it's only
been on about a month at this point I
think it came out September 21st or
something like that and I would
definitely recommend it it definitely
has something for everybody you'll find
at least one or two stories in there
that you like so if you've read it let
me know what you think about it in the
comments and what do you read Around the
Halloween season and that'll do it for
this tomes of Terror I will see you guys
again on the next one bye